Hola son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
pero en este espacio analizamos y
conversamos sobre los temas más
destacados de la semana los más
destacados en los últimos cinco días
bienvenidos esto es una semana en el
mundo aquí en France 24 para conversar
sobre los temas que hemos seleccionado
para el programa de hoy saludamos a
Stephanie echavarría ella es editor
Internacional del diario el tiempo en
Colombia Stephanie bienvenida cómo
termina su semana pues muy agitada
porque tuvimos las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos y otros temas
internacionales que por supuesto
mantuvieron la atención en el público
Entonces ha sido bastante movida esta
semana la selección es tema central del
programa de hoy también está con
nosotros Johan Ramírez periodista
corresponsal para América Latina del
Canal alemán dolcebelle Muy buenas
tardes Johan bienvenido y Cómo terminó
esta semana también de una manera
bastante agitada como mi tema es América
Latina siguiéndole la pista Las
lecciones en Brasil que Todavía siguen
dejando de que hablar aunque Yair
bolsonaro reconoció digamos La derrota
Pero sigue siendo un tema importante en
la región Claro que sí Y desde la ciudad
de Buenos Aires en Argentina se une a
esta conversación Carolina amoroso ella
es periodistas especialista en temas
internacionales del Canal tn todo
noticias más adelante vamos a estar
entonces Estableciendo conexión con ella
para incorporarla a este debate
acompáñenos también con sus opiniones
con todos los comentarios las preguntas
que ustedes quieran hacer sobre los
diferentes temas que vamos a tratar hoy
en nuestras redes sociales ya las
conocen arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 para que dejen
todos sus comentarios comienzo Entonces
por el tema de Estados Unidos allí
continúa el recuento de los votos
después de las elecciones de medio
término está en juego la renovación
total de esas 435 sillas que componen la
cámara representantes también 35 escaños
en el senado y 36 gobernaciones
estatales la pugna es muy estrecha
escaño por escaño Y esa marea roja que
se esperaba por parte de los
republicanos no tuvo lugar todavía no
hay resultados definitivos allí en
Estados Unidos pero eso sí el estado de
Georgia tendrá que ir a una segunda
vuelta hay quienes dicen incluso que el
destino político de Estados Unidos en
estas elecciones va a ser resuelto allí
en Georgia pero otro estado por ejemplo
Florida ya tiene definido su panorama y
repite gobernador republicano Ruanda
santis se mantiene en la gobernación del
estado de Florida que muchos también lo
dan como un posible candidato
presidencial para las próximas
elecciones presidenciales comienzo
entonces aquí la ronda en la mesa como
procede el protocolo Johan comienzo por
las mujeres Stephanie impresiones que
dejan estas elecciones de medio término
esperaba muchas personas esta marea roja
Trump la impulsó como pudo haciendo
visitas los diferentes estados y
condados pero Tal parece que esa marea
Roja nunca pudo despegar como la vio
usted pues yo la veo como un buen
resultado en especial para la democracia
del sistema electoral estadounidense
porque recordemos que muchos de los
candidatos puestos a dedo por el ex
presidente Trump pues definitivamente
eran negacionistas del proceso electoral
presidencial pasado y negaban el triunfo
de biden sin pruebas entonces creo que
fue una jornada que da alivio que por
supuesto temas como el derecho al aborto
tuvieron el peso y por supuesto también
la presión sobre el temor de que los
republicanos pudiera generar cambios en
derechos civiles y sociales en la
sociedad estadounidense sin embargo por
supuesto bailes no puede cantar Victoria
ni los demócratas en cierta medida
porque no fue un triunfo digamos que
supieron hacer a pulso sino que se vio
también la debilidad en el momento de
los argumentos y de ofrecerle a la gente
unas garantías por supuesto a lo que se
suma la crisis económica que está
atravesando el país y el mundo y otros
temas que estarán ahí candentes y como
bien lo señala Pues por supuesto rondes
antes ya se perfila como el candidato
que quiere hacerle frente a las
elecciones presidenciales y por supuesto
a quien ya se estima Que también será
candidato el ex presidente Donald Trump
vamos a ver cómo se va poniendo ese
panorama electoral de Cara a las
presidenciales Johan su sus impresiones
iniciales de estas elecciones pues
también queda en entredichos la figura
de Donald Trump el liderazgo de Donald
Trump no que parecía un personaje súper
Sólido y muchos de sus candidatos o no
ganaron o lograron victorias muy
estrechas o algunos están todavía por
allí peleando votos para ver si logran
ganar de manera que eso también dejan
entre dicho está tan anunciada
candidatura que seguramente el lunes ha
dicho que va a ser un gran anuncio pues
Seguramente se va a lanzar pero tal vez
ahora con menos fuerza no y por otro
lado el partido demócrata también sale
fortalecido de alguna forma No si bien
no tiene una victoria es un resultado
mucho mejor del que anticipaban las
encuestas del que anticipaban también
todos los expertos manera que pues si el
presidente vaya bien tiene razones para
por lo menos estar tranquilo este fin de
semana no Porque puede imaginarse unos
dos años mucho menos horribles de los
que él había dicho antes de la elección
puedo viajar hasta Egipto a visitar la
27 tema que vamos a tratar más adelante
sin tener tantos problemas en casa Puede
irse a Egipto un poco más tranquilo se
conecta desde la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Carolina ella es periodista de la cadena
todo noticias Tere Carolina bienvenida
Gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
y Carolina para ir cerrando el tema de
Trump y de la ola roja algunos analistas
dicen que justamente fue Donald Trump el
culpable que esa ola Roja de los
republicanos no alcanzara el vuelo que
ellos esperaban ganando gobernaciones
escaños y bueno diferentes cargos
también de elección regional y estatal
bueno a ver primero los los alumnos a
todos los escuchaba con mucho interés Me
parece que leerlo por la negativa no
Buscando el ando del Mariscal de una
derrota en términos de no el resultado
que se esperaba Me parece que subestimar
a una cantidad muy significativa de
ciudadanos y sectores recién escuchaba
la colega hablar de las mujeres de lo
que pasó en materia de derechos civiles
de lo que pasó con un tema absolutamente
clave me parece la discusión pública en
Estados Unidos que es el tema del aborto
me parece parece que
darle Incluso en ese contexto la
centralidad absoluta a la estrategia de
Trump es subestimar lo que esa
manifestación por la positiva puede
significar
en términos electorales no por otro lado
Me parece que decir que
esto saca a a Donald Trump del centro de
la escena es subestimar a Donald Trump y
en cuanto a la capacidad que ha tenido
de construir construir el protagonismo
en el partido republicano y no entender
que en los próximos dos años son en
términos políticos ciencia ficción no
todo puede pasar pero te sumaría un
aspecto que sí me parece importante a la
hora de analizarlo qué que esté un poco
más ratificado de lo que se esperaba el
oficialismo en los Estados Unidos es
también una señal hacia el mundo no de
fortaleza interna o de mayor fortaleza
interna para Joe menos mayor de la que
se preveía en un mundo que está en
guerra en un mundo que de alguna manera
le exige a los Estados Unidos un peso
específico mayor y que por supuesto por
supuesto Un gobierno débil internamente
no le puede dar no me parece que esta es
un aspecto que hay que tener en cuenta a
la hora de pensar también a los Estados
Unidos en el mundo No claro y eso que no
tenemos todavía los resultados de cómo
va a quedar configurado el congreso en
Estados Unidos que eso también nos
indica Cómo se va a manejar la política
exterior de este país como queden
equilibradas las cargas en las dos
cámaras Carolina continuó con usted hay
mucha expectativa y yo le digo Aquí en
la re 24 Están haciendo apuestas qué es
lo que va a decir Donald Trump el 15 de
noviembre cuál va a ser ese anuncio qué
es lo que va a decir Donald Trump qué
cree usted
la verdad que la verdad que me resulta
difícil creerlo pero difícil esbozar una
hipótesis de qué es lo que puede llegar
a llegar a decir Pero te repito esto
anterior no me resulta muy difícil creer
en un en un Donald Trump no ejerciendo
un protagonismo en la escena política de
Estados Unidos porque ya está habituado
hacerlo
Me parece que hay que pensar quizás que
si el resultado ha sido más adverso no
en contraposición a las a las
proyecciones que tenía me lo puedo
imaginar Tejiendo alguna alguna
estrategia no con alguna otra figura
pero incluso hasta dentro de su clan no
se ha hablado muy hablado mucho de la
figura de banca Trump yo miraría muy de
cerca también eso y te diría que no No
subestimaría para nada su capacidad para
mantener cierto protagonismo incluso
cuando cuando esto que ha sucedido en
las elecciones de medio término ha sido
un revés político y aquí en el estudio
que piensen ustedes Estefany Bueno yo
creo que él sí estaba esperando una
Arrolladora Victoria dominicana para
lanzar oficialmente su candidatura a las
próximas presidenciales sin embargo es
cierto que el panorama le cambió y que
ahora pues buscará atribuirse de otras
maneras lo que sí ya estoy segura es que
él no buscará hacerle el poder a alguien
más él será el candidato que candidatura
a ustedes que les dice estos resultados
que ustedes lo lo están comentando que
hayan sido tan reñidos esto evidencia
que efectivamente eran candidaturas
flojas por parte de los dos partidos o
es otro ejemplo esta polarización
inmensa que está viviendo Estados Unidos
Johan para hacer la ronda la inversa yo
creo que antes de la elección se hablaba
mucho de que la democracia estaba en
juego en Estados Unidos pero que el tema
principal que preocupaba los ciudadanos
era la economía y sin embargo parece que
viendo los resultados Parece que la
gente pensó en la democracia también no
y no dio ese respaldo ciego digamos
ideológico a Donald Trump o al partido
republicano sino que buscó otros
candidatos tal vez guardar esos valores
estadounidenses y yo creo que eso es una
muestra tal vez de una cierta madurez
política de los ciudadanos porque en
América Latina hemos visto situaciones
muy similares en las que hay unos
líderes populistas que salen y no se
abordan los temas esenciales que es la
pobreza la desigualdad la salud y aún
así la gente vota por esos candidatos
populistas Más allá de que no ofrezcan
soluciones reales a los problemas
cotidianos de los ciudadanos de manera
que creo que hay una diferencia allí en
esos resultados y creo que sí hubo una
preocupación Más allá del tema económico
si creo que los ciudadanos en el fondo
terminaron dándole un apoyo y pensando
más en la democracia en Estados Unidos y
Carolina sus impresiones
bueno sin dudas creo que en línea con lo
que con lo que lo que estaban enumerando
recién Me parece que hay algo en materia
de derechos sociales que ha pesado pero
también en materia de preservación de la
institucionalidad no hay incluso algunos
Mira el escenario mundial Aunque es
difícil mirar el escenario mundial con
todas las cosas que suceden en Estados
Unidos en el frente interno con el
incremento del costo de vida y demás
Pero si uno mira el escenario mundial Me
parece que
están estos fantasmas de
resquebrajamientos institucionales de
modelos populistas de izquierda y de
izquierda y derecha no modelos y digamos
o que plantea plantean una crisis de la
de la Democracia liberal y me parece que
es este fantasma el que está llevando a
ratificar algunas cosas que otrora
quizás resultaban Más intangibles o más
lejanas o menos urgentes no que las
necesidades económicas Me parece que de
repente hay valores press que empezaron
a jugarse mucho más en las elecciones a
mí recientemente me tocó cubrir la
selección las elecciones en Brasil y me
parece sin dudas que en buena parte de
ese caudal de votos votos que le dio una
victoria en segunda vuelta hay que decir
por una distancia muy pequeña a Luis
Ignacio luna de Silva buena parte de
esos votos no son el voto lulista sino
que son un voto que esto que está
mirando a esos fantasmas de
resquebrajamiento institucional o a esos
miedos por la vigencia del sistema de
democracia liberal tal como se lo conoce
no Bueno lo cierto Es que este capítulo
de La historia en estas elecciones de
Estados Unidos sigue abierto el recuento
de los votos continúa todavía no está
nada definido incluso esto se puede
extender hasta el mes de diciembre poco
a poco iremos Sabiendo Cómo se va
configurando tanto el congreso como la
cámara representantes las gobernaciones
estatales Y estos cargos regionales que
también estaban en disputa tema que
queda abierto tema que seguramente vamos
a tener que ir tocando a lo largo de la
próxima semana y de los próximos días y
lo dejamos por ahí con puntos
suspensivos esta historia yo paso a otro
tema importante de la semana que tenemos
para la agenda del programa y es la
Cumbre climática mundial de cop27 en
donde se busca poner en marcha todos
esos compromisos medioambientales que
fueron pactados en versiones anteriores
o en otros escenarios similares a esta
Cumbre climática Hay muchísimo reclamos
por parte de los países en vías de
desarrollo que piden compromisos y
compensaciones por parte de los países
que más contaminan estamos hablando de
Estados Unidos de Rusia de China de
India entre otros el lema de este año es
juntos para la implementación pero como
ya lo decía hay muchas promesas hay
muchos compromisos sí se va a lograr una
implementación de todos esos acuerdos la
Cumbre ha servido también para otros
propósitos por lo menos para América
Latina ha sido un escenario
internacional una gran vitrina como
hemos visto a Nicolás Maduro relajándose
en la escena internacional también
Gustavo Petro el presidente de Colombia
teniendo un primer fogueo con
mandatarios de alto nivel con
funcionarios
hablándole al mundo sobre su propuesta
medioambiental su propuesta
Sí medioambiental y de la paz total en
Colombia y también veíamos incluso al
presidente electo de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva y Joe biden también ya
estuvo por allí entre otros mandatarios
cambiamos entonces la página comienzo
por Carolina en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires preguntándole esta cop 27 muchas
promesas china que es uno de los países
que más contamina dijo ya no más
compromisos es hora de actuar Pero pues
eso es lo que llamamos esperando ya
muchísimas cop 27 desde hace mucho
tiempo
Bueno me parece que parece que la clave
para que esto se termine trasladando en
políticas públicas para el cumplimiento
de los compromisos Me parece que la
clave está en las demandas sociales
Mira Hace algunos días
estuve en una conversación bueno ustedes
saben que el campo el sector
agropecuario es el corazón de la matriz
productiva de la Argentina y una de las
cosas que decía un referente del sector
es ahora o ser sustentable o no sé o no
sé es digamos no estás en el mapa no y
hablaba de optimizar la eficiencia pero
al mismo tiempo por supuesto tener en
consideración esto que se ha convertido
en un imperativo moral Pero también en
un imperativo de negocio te diría que me
parece que está más en manos de la
ciudadanías y de los electorados poner
esto en el centro de los reclamos
públicos para que En definitiva haya
políticas públicas porque si no vamos a
seguir firmando memorando un
entendimiento miento y después la
cuestión va a terminar siendo lo que es
no un puñado de buenas intenciones
hay algunos aspectos que complican la
cosa no estar hablando de una crisis
energética como como la que estamos
viviendo como efecto colateral de la
guerra estar hablando hablando de
algunos problemas muy grandes en materia
de abastecimiento de alimentos algunos
de las grandes crisis que se están dando
por la guerra y por otros aspectos por
supuesto han generado algunos desafíos
no para el cumplimiento de los
compromisos Me parece que la clave está
en las demandas sociales demandas
sociales por este lado Stephanie su
opinión muchos compromisos muchos pactos
pero poca acción en la acción también Yo
creo que esa crítica que vimos en la
Cumbre de líderes de la cop 27 los
países pobres exigiéndole a los ricos
que realmente aportan los recursos para
que ellos preserven las selvas los
océanos y todos los recursos hídricos
que están en estos países y que por
demás como poner ejemplo República
democrática del Congo en donde
insistieron en que 500 millones de
dólares que ni siquiera fueron
desembolsados del todo fueron
suficientes para equiparar lo que iba a
pasar en la explotación de hidrocarburos
de las selvas y de todo el sector
petrolero entonces creo que es clave
también que los países ricos realmente
aporten el dinero para que los pobres
empiecen a proteger y preservar estas
zonas tan importantes y Definitivamente
ya llegará unos objetivos mucho más
específicos porque lo que estaba pactado
en las anteriores pues vimos que ya no
se va a cumplir Y que lo que dice
Carolina la crisis la coyuntura de este
momento la coyuntura internacional a
raíz de la guerra en Ucrania pues
dificulta avanzar en muchos en muchos de
los planes y plazos que ya estaban
estipulados impresiones iniciales sobre
este tema pues tenemos yo soy bastante
pesimista en este en este asunto no
tenemos uno siete años 27 años
celebrando cups en el mundo desde 1995 y
prometiendo cada vez que se van a
reducir los las actividades que producen
el calentamiento global y tenemos 27
años aumentando los gases que provocan
el calentamiento global es decir 27 años
sin cumplir ni una sola promesa o muy
pocas en realidad no pero acciones
reales que impacten y que disminuyan el
calentamiento global no había ninguna en
27 años de manera que no veo como esta
cop 27 pudiera ofrecer resultados
distintos creo que es un escenario una
vitrina en los que todos los líderes se
montan en la ola no en esa ola de ser
modernos y de apoyar el del digamos la
protección del medio ambiente pero luego
regresan a su país y se consiguen con
unos contextos que los obligan a llevar
unas políticas públicas distintas o Pues
dentro de las de las limitaciones de sus
modos de producción de sus capacidades
de legislar de sus capacidades de
ofrecer políticas públicas con el
congreso es decir pongamos el ejemplo de
Lula no que llega ahora al Brasil como
presidente y hay muchas esperanzas de
que ahora sí él pueda proteger el medio
ambiente luego de una administración
desastrosa de bolsonaro Lula ha
prometido proteger la amazonía de una
manera sin precedentes no 6 de los nueve
gobernadores de la amazonía brasileña
son aliados de bolsonaro de manera que
para que él pueda aplicar allí esas
políticas va a tener que lograr
consensos o lograr el apoyo de estos
gobernadores cómo lo va a hacer cediendo
entonces esas promesas tan ambiciosas
que ha hecho va a tener que reducir las
va a tener que negociarlas entonces pues
en el fondo creo que termina siendo esta
promesa pues muy bonitos pero en la
práctica muy poco yo me quedo pensando
lo titulamos en diferentes medios
internacionales esos reclamos que piden
los países en vías de desarrollo a los
países desarrollados volvemos a los
mismos escenarios de Somos pobres
entonces ayudo y nos tenemos
dificultades económicas Entonces
ayúdenos es muy difícil que los países
enviar desarrollo en este escenario
armen bloques se unan lo digo porque por
ejemplo Brasil están conversaciones con
la República democrática del Congo y con
Indonesia para un gran plan de
preservación de selvas justamente
liderado por Indonesia que es un país
que ha avanzado muchísimo en esa materia
Pero uno no ve Unión de los países debía
desarrollo para plantarse frente a los
otros más allá de simplemente pedir
dinero ayudas sino que formar un bloque
y lanzar propuestas o avanzar en algo
porque nos cuesta tanto nos cuesta tanto
justamente porque las necesidades
locales y las exigencias domésticas Pues
hacen que los gobiernos como bien lo
decían pues se concentren en su
electoral básicamente pero creo que lo
que hemos visto en esta ola por supuesto
caso ejemplo América Latina en este
surgimiento de gobiernos de izquierda o
progresistas sin duda algunas ya están
perfilándose como una plan de
integración no solamente regional sino
llegar a otras latitudes del planeta
para encontrar sintonía en distintos
temas en este caso los medioambientales
y poder plantar cara de una manera Más
directa creo que en esta cop 27 lo están
haciendo Están teniendo una voz mucho
más potente y poderosa sin embargo por
supuesto requiere negociar Y si algo les
enseñó la pandemia y Esperamos que así
sea es que la cooperación es clave para
avanzar en estos temas de nivel global
si bien no tenían de llevar a nosotros
allá para debatir sobre este tema y
directamente Carolina Como vi usted está
con 27 que le ha servido de vitrina a
los mandatarios suramericanos para
mostrarse y codearse allí con
mandatarios europeos y poder llevar
propuestas un poco más aterrizadas desde
el lado suramericano Vimos a Nicolás
Maduro estrechando manos con con
Emmanuel macco el presidente colombiano
también allí hablando sobre su plan de
paz y su plan medioambiental que ha
recibido buenas críticas por parte de la
comunidad internacional
bueno varias cosas no ese Bueno ese
saludo entre más entre macrón y maduro
del que por supuesto estamos hablando
todos me parece que también muestra que
a que que muchas veces la necesidad
termina a veces exponiendo entre entre
comillas el pragmatismo de la política y
trataría de usar no no un término que
suene tanto eufemismo como pragmatismo
pero la volatilidad en materia de
valores no digo el régimen de Nicolás
maduro tiene una investigación en curso
en la Corte Penal Internacional nada
menos que por crimen por crímenes de
lesa humanidad y seguimos sumando
informes el de la misión independiente
de la ONU uno de los uno de los últimos
que ratifican que esto ha sido un plan
sistemático de supresión de derechos
fundamentales entiendo las necesidades
entiendo la crisis energética pero
realmente es creo mucho pedir que se
entienda ese sacudón de mano por fuera
de ese ese pragmatismo Acaso
imperdonable no en el contexto de
violación derechos humanos sistemática
en Venezuela realmente es muy pero muy
triste de ver eso verlo a Nicolás Maduro
en ese escenario escenario realmente
bastante decepcionante No por lo que
Nicolás Maduro representa para la
historia de América Latina por lo que
representa para para la bandera de los
Derechos Humanos en América Latina no un
resurgimiento de su de su imagen a nivel
internacional después de haber sido
prácticamente dejado de lado por más de
50 países Johan Claro pero es que era
difícil no digamos la América Latina
está transformándose políticamente está
dando un giro hacia la izquierda lo que
hace 10 años era un continente de
derechos ahora está de nuevo haciendo un
continente de izquierda de manera que
Europa y occidente digamos Estados
Unidos tiene que replantearse esa
política de cara América Latina Porque
si si en bloque América Latina exige
como ahora cuando el Gustavo Petro
visitó Caracas no que pidió que
Venezuela sea incluida nuevamente en
algunos tratados en algunas de estas
confederaciones de Naciones si en bloque
América Latina comienza a pedir eso que
va los países van a seguir aislando
maduro o van a aislar ahora entonces a
toda América de manera que hay un
pragmatismo allí que se impone pero creo
que de forma de de justamente Esa es la
gran contradicción de esta copa 27 no
que termina siendo un escenario de bueno
para reafirmar liderazgos para
establecer vínculos para
más o menos modelar la geopolítica
internacional y no para ir al fondo del
problema y qué es lo que lo que debería
hacer esta top que es precisamente
atacar el problema central del cambio
climático Más allá de Por eso yo decía
que soy muy pesimista con esto y
Santiago la la cop 21 la que se celebró
en París en el año 2015 yo vivía en
pareja en ese momento y recuerdo que era
una cosa impresionante había un ambiente
en la ciudad de que el mundo iba a
cambiar a partir del 21 Ah sí a mejorar
salvamos el planeta después se sacó 21
los días las muchachas llorando recuerdo
en esa conferencia Y qué pasó después Un
par de años después Estados Unidos se
salió con Donald Trump en la presidencia
abandonó ese acuerdo de París y en qué
quedó sacó 21 en promesas para que les
pasa a ustedes también que si Piensan en
esta cop 27 la imagen la fotografía que
deja hasta Cup es ese apretón de manos
Macro maduro en vez de un acuerdo bueno
Todavía faltan muchos días para que
termine pero la foto que nos deja hasta
ahora es esa
Estefanía sí creo además que se
concentra en luego la visita de maduro a
París el respaldo por supuesto de
Francia todo el proceso de diálogo con
la oposición entonces finalmente es más
como una búsqueda de oportunismo
político y lo que bien decía Johan que
en realidad tener el Eje Central en el
cambio climático en la lucha en qué
vamos a hacer con esto y en realmente
poner unas tareas mucho más puntuales y
que no sean tan efímeras y tan
ambiciosas que al final no se van a
cumplir pues vamos a ver si esa foto
final de la cop 27 que por lo menos
tenemos hasta ahora cambia al final de
esta Cumbre todavía restan varios días
por delante para ver cuáles son las
conclusiones de este Encuentro Mundial
lo vamos a analizar también aquí cuando
vez que ya tengamos algún resultado de
algún compromiso por parte de los países
también destacado esta semana fue el
retiro de las tropas rusas de la ciudad
de gerson que es la mayor ciudad del
grupo de urbes que habían caído ya en
manos del ejército ruso gerson es un
punto de suma importancia a nivel
geoestratégico y de acuerdo al
presidente de ucranianski las tropas
ucranianas Ya entraron a la ciudad ya
están caminando por las calles del
centro de gerson
Moscú Indicó que este retiro de las
tropas no cambia en absoluto el estatus
de la ciudad y de la región que fue
recordemos anexada al territorio de la
federación de Rusia ahora simplemente
les queda el río niéper separando a los
dos ejércitos del lado izquierdo los
ucranianos y del lado derecho las tropas
rusas ponemos también la lupa entonces
en el tema de Rusia
mucho se ha hablado en la presa en la
prensa occidental sobre este retiro de
las tropas muchos especula sobre una re
de tropas rusas y que tal vez el
presidente Putin está dando marcha atrás
a todos estos logros territoriales que
habían alcanzado en los últimos meses yo
aquí análisis hace usted pues escuchando
lo que dice el kremlin es no representa
para nada una derrota no ha dicho que no
es para nada humillante y y que esos
reterritorios como tú decías siguen
formando parte de Rusia no luego de la
de la anexión que hiciera bueno Cómo
podemos seguir formando parte de Rusia
si no tienes el control territorial esa
es una una contradicción ya de base pero
también esto se podría entender como una
como una estrategia y justamente las
autoridades ucranianas creo que lo lo
entienden de esa manera advirtiendo y
pidiendo a los ciudadanos que no
regresen tan rápidamente a las regiones
liberadas por temor de que haya
explosivos por ejemplo de que hayan
dejado zonas minadas o de que se puedan
producir ataques de manera que esto
podría ser simplemente una estrategia es
decir esto es una guerra bastante
difícil de entender muchas veces y
absolutamente impredecible de manera que
decir que esto es una derrota definitiva
Pues en la teoría aparece una derrota
enorme para Putin las primeras regiones
que ocupó de Rusia luego de la invasión
Cuando comenzó el 24 de febrero de
manera que esto en teoría es una gran
derrota pero hay que darle tiempo creo
que es muy pronto para tratar de dar una
lectura a este asunto Estefani también
conversando con algunos de los colegas
En la redacción hablábamos como como
este hecho se toma para el discurso de
ambos lados entonces Ucrania lo muestra
como una victoria regresamos a jerson y
el kremlin Pese a que es una retirada de
sus tropas dicen No es simplemente un
movimiento más que uno hace en la guerra
uno va hacia adelante va hacia atrás
parte de la estrategia o de los
movimientos que hace el discurso acá
vuelve a entrar en en la escena lo
aprovechan los medios los medios
occidentales hemos caído en ese discurso
por parte de Ucrania en este caso muy
victorioso Yo sí debo decir que los
medios occidentales hemos tendido a
cubrir la guerra desde una mirada muy a
favor de Ucrania que por supuesto tiene
también un peso sobre la lógica y la
dinámica política Europea estadounidense
y en esto es importante decir que gerson
es clave porque lo que pretendía el
kremlin aquí era evitar que o aislar a
Ucrania del mar Negro y de esta salida
tan importante y por supuesto generar la
conexión con crimea allá anexionada de
manera ilegal hace unos años entonces lo
que vemos ahora es que estos discursos
pues justamente nos muestran dos caras
que generan latencia y lo que a mí más
me preocupa es precisamente la población
civil porque Todos quieren regresar y la
mayoría de las personas que han sido
desplazadas De esta zona ya están
regresando y Están volviendo en masa a
querer quizá volver a pasar a los fines
Pues el fin de año en su hogar y ahí
viene la preocupación de Cuál es el plan
y cuál es la estrategia de Putin cuando
ha insistido y vemos que su discurso
también se ha mantenido en que son las
tropas ucranianas las que están
generando distintos bombardeos y ataques
para justificar por supuesto situaciones
tan preocupantes como que ataque o
llegue a la central de saprilla a la
central nuclear que por supuesto es de
suma preocupación para el mundo entero
Carolina su perspectiva sobre este tema
de la guerra en Ucrania los medios
occidentales hemos caído en ese juego
del discurso y también le extiendo y le
prolongo un poquito más la pregunta y ya
comienza a bajar un poco la importancia
del tema de Ucrania en las redacciones
de los medios internacionales Usted cree
que ya estamos empezando a dejar el tema
un poco de lado y a cubrirlo desde un
punto de vista un poco más alejado y se
está estancando un poco el el conflicto
varias cosas primero Sí me parece que
que se está produciendo un
no sé si llamarlo un vacío informativo
pero si una baja muy importante en el
caudal informativo Me parece que esto es
que esto es peligroso porque esto genera
la sensación de que se empieza a
naturalizar En definitiva del horror no
con respecto a lo que decían por
supuesto jerson es un lugar un lugar un
punto absolutamente estratégico al igual
que lo fue harkie al igual que para
Rusia no era el anillo de Kim no en las
primeras semanas de la guerra Nosotros
con el equipo de equipo de tn estuvimos
me tocó estar en las tres primeras
semanas de la guerra y les puedo
asegurar que
permanentemente llegaban noticias que
tenían que ver con las hostilidades
incesantes en territorios como personas
así que que esta noticia tiene
particular importancia con los respecto
a lo que decís de la guerra narrativa
porque también hay una guerra que es de
orden informativa o narrativa bueno no
hay que perder de vista algo No aquí un
país invadido hay un país cuya soberanía
está siendo violada no entonces ahí me
parece que ya hay un Punto de partida
que
digo esta muchas veces lo que lo que se
habla o se Comenta mucho de esta
pretencion bueno atención con la
interpretación que tenemos sobre lo que
significa la equidistancia porque violar
la soberanía un payaso está mal y lo que
está mal está mal y el trabajo de los
periodistas es también decir que aquí
hay un país un país invadiendo y con
respecto a la resistencia militar
también hay que entender que la
resistencia de Ucrania tiene un está
enraizada en un tejido que es la
sociedad sociedad civil la sociedad
civil ucraniana y créanme porque lo he
visto desde en escuelas hasta en
empresas se reconfiguró por completo
para ponerse al servicio de la
resistencia para ponerse al servicio de
la resistencia militar que está también
compuesta por lo que ellos llaman la
defensa territorial no que son los
civiles que han tomado las armas con lo
intrínsecamente relacional llenar la
sociedad civil con las fuerzas de
resistencia las más formales y en inglés
para hacerle frente a la invasión rusa
no
volvemos ahora dejamos el tema de
Ucrania ya para el cierre el último
bloque del programa volvemos entonces a
la región de América Latina Tenemos que
hablar obviamente de Colombia y
Venezuela que dieron un paso más en el
restablecimiento de las relaciones
diplomáticas y también las relaciones
económicas entre ambos países esta
semana ambos países recuperaron los
vuelos comerciales fue justamente la
aerolínea Estatal colombiana la que
realizó ese primer vuelo entre Bogotá y
Caracas ahí ven ustedes las imágenes del
avión aterrizando en el aeropuerto de
maiquetía
esto marca para ustedes comienzo por
Johan que es venezolano si esto marca un
buen ritmo en ese se está teniendo un
ritmo fluido digámoslo así en ese
restablecimiento de las relaciones Pues
yo no sé un buen ritmo Depende de qué de
qué visión tengamos no de qué óptica le
queramos dar yo creo que para los
ciudadanos es algo positivo en el fondo
Quienes se van a beneficiar de esos
vuelos son la gente que necesitaba ir de
Caracas a Bogotá o viceversa y que tenía
que pasar por pa por República
Dominicana simplemente hacer el trayecto
por tierra y cruzar la frontera por
ejemplo entonces creo que en el fondo es
eso lo que beneficia principalmente a
los ciudadanos el restablecimiento de
relaciones diplomáticas que haya
nuevamente se desconsulares en ambos
países es algo ventajoso para los
ciudadanos pero creo que eso lo que
plantea o lo que replantea es la
ese reconocimiento o desconocimiento que
se le daba a maduro bueno por parte de
Colombia ya ya está claro que quedó en
el pasado Pero regional y no solamente
regional sino Bueno ya con eso lo que
decíamos ante más de 50 países en un
momento desconocieron a Nicolás Maduro
qué van a hacer ahora y puertas adentro
abren un debate fundamental de
supervivencia para la oposición política
en el país qué va a hacer la oposición
en Venezuela Qué vas a hacer con la
figura de Juan guaidó luego de que ya no
solamente Gustavo Petro sino que Lula da
Silva seguramente cuando ASUME el poder
en Brasil el primero de enero el año
próximo muy rápidamente seguramente
reconocerá y restablecerá relaciones con
Venezuela y con Nicolás Maduro Pero
entonces qué va a ser la oposición para
tratar de subsistir en un contexto en el
que participan elecciones presidenciales
a la vuelta de la esquina de manera que
creo que el debate de fondo es eso Como
esas relaciones se van normalizando y
cómo es la posición tiene que
replantearse el futuro político y no hay
un candidato claro rápidamente Stephanie
para el cierre que ya me queda pocos
minutos pues yo quisiera también poner
que justamente Este cambio pues ponen en
plano las debilidades y es unos tiquetes
excesivamente costosos y unas aerolíneas
que poco a poco se Irán montando pero
vemos el caso de conviasa que la afectan
las sanciones estadounidenses y que por
supuesto eso también ralentiza el
proceso de normalización Así que los
desafíos son amplios sin embargo por
algo había que empezar y creo que esto
beneficia en general a la comunidad a
las comunidades de ambas naciones y
Carolina para el cierre muy puntual por
favor su opinión
bueno por supuesto esto coincido con
esto que marcaba no la desconexión que
que muchas veces afecta un montón de
gente que tiene a familia en la diáspora
bueno sin duda tenía muchas muchas
muchas consecuencias que afectaban a las
personas y es importante que se
restablezca la conexión pero pero yo
creo que digamos cuando cuando la
conversación Es sobre sobre Venezuela En
definitiva para mí la conversación
central termina siendo sobre tus manos
no tanto una discusión sobre afinidades
ideológicas y es muy triste Ver América
Latina más condicionada por la
solidariedades partidarias de los
líderes de turno de nuestros países que
por las convicciones en materia de
defensa de Derechos Humanos no Entonces
todos estos cambios Me parece que están
más supeditados adaptados a simpatías
partidarias o personales que a
convicciones profundas sobre los
derechos de las personas Pues con esa
con esa declaración con esas palabras de
Carolina finalizamos el programa
Stephanie y Johan de estudio les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
Carolina también la ciudad de Buenos
Aires Muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado es todo por esta semana la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Keila maestro y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan dejando todos sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con France 24
[Música]